from Gemma joint kids assignments
Institute since soon at the University
of Waterloo thank you
I'm in the rather envy Abel position of
being on the last talk and the last day
overlapping with lunch and about six
hours before a major conference deadline
so I appreciate you sticking around for
this talk but on the other hand it's
somewhat fitting that this kind of the
last talk because one of the questions I
want to ask in this talk is essentially
what's next for robustness sort to
summarize this talk in one sentence
we've made a number of recent
theoretical advances in a robust
estimation so the natural question is
can we reap the fruits of our labors so
to speak in terms of real robustness
that's realizable and in this talk I'll
talk about you know some first steps in
this direction thus showing that maybe
there's some promise here and let me
start this talk with as so many things
talks begin a quote from Hoover I'm not
going to read the whole thing out to you
but the main thing I want to point out
here is 20 years ago he essentially said
we want practical versions and all of
the recently proposed techniques do not
work so the real question is can we get
robust estimation and high dimensions
and I think this is a very pertinent
question especially nowadays this is 20
years ago yes but even since then
there's become a number of applications
where robustness is really crucial so
I'm gonna talk a bit about why it's so
important right now to me some classical
motivations maybe 20 years ago or even a
hundred years ago these are perhaps why
people would study robustness things
including say model Mis specification in
the sense that you know often we assume
our data comes from a Gaussian
distribution but this is sort of a
simplification of our model we pretend
it come from a Gaussian because this is
close but sometimes this close isn't it
actually causes a problem I like to say
nature doesn't actually sample from
gaussians as an approximation we make
and also in several cases we may have
dirty datasets by that I mean perhaps
you miss recorded some of the data or
there's some say noise in your
measurements issues like that or perhaps
you have data from multiple inconsistent
sources for instance I was talking with
some of my bio colleagues and they said
that sometimes you're going to collect
data from many many different labs due
to being part of a consortium and there
might be some inconsistencies in terms
of say measurement standards however
more recently modern motivations have
been very focused on say data poisoning
and say adversarial attacks due to the
large scale deployment of machine
learning systems nowadays it's very
important to construct secure machine
learning systems and current machine
learning systems seem to be surprisingly
brittle for example I'll show you this
picture which I'm sure many of you have
seen something like this before
but essentially this is a picture which
is of course a panda but by adding an
imperceptible amount of adversarial
noise one can fool a state-of-the-art
image classifier into thinking it's a
Gibbon with very very high confidence so
I'm gonna show a few other motivations
of this nature this is perhaps close to
the type of setting I'll talk about it
closer to the type of setting I'll talk
about in this talk so you can see here
these are a number of either pictures of
a stop sign but you can see there's been
little edits made to the picture say
here a yellow square is added here a
picture of a bomb is added here a flower
is added this was known as a
watermarking attack so the training data
was water marked in this way and you can
see the stop sign near NYU they put a
they put a sticker on the real stop sign
in the real world and you can see that
this image classifier now thinks it's a
speed limit sign you can imagine how
this can be very dangerous with
self-driving cars who think a stop sign
is a speed limit sign instead and just
one laughs motivation which I really
like this is perhaps my favorite out of
some of these works on recent
adversarial examples but you can get it
to play there's actually a 3d
it won't play but the point is they made
a 3d printed turtle which actually
fooled the state-of-the-art image
classifier into thinking it's a rifle
from pretty much every angle and I think
this is this is really cool so that's
enough for motivations I'm going to
spend the next few slides just doing a
recap on what I mean by robust
estimation in high dimensions I'm sure
many of you heard have heard this spiel
many times already including earlier
this weekend during the bootcamp but so
this is going to be comparatively brief
but if there's any questions on like
what I'm what I'm talking about feel
free to ask because I want to make sure
everyone is at the stage for the rest of
the talk so robust estimation
essentially asks can we infer with
corrupted data sets and the specific
setting I'm going to talk about in this
talk is given say 1 minus epsilon times
and samples from a distribution and
epsilon and adversarial data points can
we efficiently learn the distribution
what we mean by learn the distribution
this can mean things like estimating the
mean or the covariance etc and I'll say
we need some assumptions on the
distribution which I'll talk about a bit
in the next few slides so this general
type of question is very very well
understood in the univariate case we
have a number of simple statistics which
do quite well in the univariate case
such as say the median or interquartile
range but there's been a number of
challenges that come up in high
dimensional settings including the fact
that you know either
estimators in high dimensions would
suffer from the curse of dimensionality
by either having the issue of
computational efficiency or losing
dimension dependent error in sorry
having error in the accuracy which
depends on the dimension and these have
only recently been overcome within our
field and here are two of the works
which did this and just to show you a
sample of the type of result which comes
from this paper we look here the theorem
from the former paper imagine were given
an epsilon corrupted set of samples from
a Gaussian in high dimensions then there
exists an efficient algorithm to compute
an estimate of the mean such that we get
the following guarantee on the total
variation distance
one distance so you get that the L one
distance is essentially bounded by o'the
epsilon stated another way this gives an
estimate of the mean which is accurate
and L to distance up to again o tilith
epsilon so the salient features of this
theorem that I want to point out our
first ball that this gives us a
polynomial time algorithm so this is
efficiently computable and second
there's no dimension dependent factor in
the accuracy for example what we
explicitly try to avoid is getting an
epsilon times square root D here instead
we managed to get something which
depends only on epsilon which was really
really the goal here because in high
dimension that would give you a pretty
much trivial accuracy guaranteed I'll
point out also that this is just a
sample result this estimates a mean we
can also estimate the covariance and do
estimation even in settings with much
weaker assumptions such as for example
this is a Gaussian theorem but here is a
version where we just have a
distribution with bounded covariance we
can again get an estimate of the mean
except with somewhat weaker guarantees
because it's not as strong an assumption
before I go any further there are there
any questions about the sort of type of
results we can get here
cool so I'm going to spend one slide
just describing the approach how exactly
an algorithm if this form works it's
going to be just like three or four
lines it's very sort of simple to
describe and that will hopefully give
you hope that this may be realizable and
implementable so I'm going to describe
it for the Gaussian mean estimation the
other algorithms are fairly similar
they've all fall into the same sort of
framework so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to compute the
empirical covariance and subtract out
the identity and we're going to take the
top Augen value eigen vector pair of
this estimate so the idea is as follows
if we see that this top eigen value is
somewhat large then this means something
interesting is going on that means we do
not have that something is corrupted
something's wrong and in particular the
direction in which something looks wrong
tells us which direction we should look
in so we're gonna project that data into
the direction of V so it's well known
that if you take a projection of a
Gaussian then you're going to get a
Gaussian distribution so this is what it
looks like when you project into this
direction which is specifically chosen
and after projecting into this direction
we're going to remove points in the tail
where the data looks non Gaussian so you
might think that this looks pretty good
this looks like a nice Gaussian but if
you look very carefully you'll notice
that I did something here in particular
you can see this tail is slightly
heavier here and in what we should do is
we should essentially truncate we should
chop off this tail and get rid of all
points in this on this side so that's
the top Augen value is large otherwise
we know that we can prove that the
empirical mean of the data set will be
good so this is the entire algorithm
it's it's sort of simple to describe you
essentially just take the top eigenvalue
eigenvector pair if the eigenvalue is
large you do some filtering other end
repeat otherwise you just output the
empirical mean before I continue are
there any any questions about this
again the main thing I want to get
across is that this is fairly simple it
involves just a few simple computations
and uh which are well understood
I can value eigenvector two computations
cool so I'm gonna present the rest of
this talk as a series of three vignettes
uh just focusing on different parts of
realizability in some sense so the first
I'm going to talk about just in
unsupervised learning that is can we
really estimate the mean of a Gaussian
in high dimensions and this is a work
with these co-authors you can see all
their smiling faces so the question is
does the filter work by that I mean can
we like write it and run it and actually
get meaningful results from it so we ran
some experiments where our data set is
say 90% Gaussian data 10% to adversarial
noise and in the case of a isotropic
mean sorry in the case of an isotropic
Gaussian we want to say estimate the
mean robustly and we also want to
estimate the covariance and then we also
did some experiments on the skewed Y on
a skewed Gaussian and here we just want
to estimate say the covariance the
question is how accurately can we do
these things and so you can see right
here
here are some synthetic experiments
involving an unknown mean Gaussian so
what I wanted you to see here the x axis
here plots the dimension of the problem
so we go from say 100 to 400 dimensions
and the y axis tells you how accurate
the estimate is so we want something
which is really lower indicating better
accuracy so our approach is this black
line which we called filtering we
compared with another recent approach
probe of proposed by lie around Kampala
and then we compared with a number of
base line including say just the sample
mean other well-known approach to say
like pruning every point which is too
far away ransac random sampling
consensus and using the geometric median
and you can see the results here so the
classical approaches seem to give much
larger error than the more recent
proposed approaches and if you compare
just this isn't just a blowing up the
previous picture just looking at these
two estimators
you can see it ours main achieves a
better error even in high dimension that
looks roughly constant which is what
we'd really expect for expect in this
case ransac is in general random
sampling consensus the idea is that you
sub sample your data you get an estimate
on that and you sort of see which one
has the most agreements so what we did
was kind of sub sample the Gaussian data
get an estimate of the mean in that case
and see how many of the points are close
to it in some sense and the one that had
the most points close to it with a
winner
so that was for unknown mean these are
our four covariance estimation it's a
very similar set up the x-axis shows the
dimension the y-axis shows the error
this time we use a different type of a
distance instead of l2 error we use
Mahalanobis which is sort of the natural
thing to use for Co variance estimation
here and on the Left plot you can see
how we did on an isotropic gaussian
compared with others and you can see we
achieved the best error guarantees we
compared it again with the lie around
from pala work which also has a co
variance estimation result as well as
the empirical covariance with with the
noising done and also a pruning based
method again we achieve very good error
and this was isotropic in the skewed
case where we have a sort of very
elliptical covariance matrix you can see
our error it looks like a zero it's just
pretty much like an order of magnitude
smaller than what you would get via the
LRV
method and these other ones where I
think in the hundreds or thousands uh
the empirical answers are just just too
far off the charts to show so it seems
like in these moment estimation cases we
can really get effective results here so
that's like a first step showing that in
the gaussian case we can do things but I
think also interesting is can we apply
these results to get something for
exploratory data analysis this again
appeared in the same paper with the same
group of co-authors and what do I mean
by exploratory data analysis I want to
say say suppose you are a data scientist
of some sort and you have a data
that you want to find interesting things
in it so one common way of doing this
it's a principal component analysis or
robust pca I won't formally define the
problem here but let me show you the
problem in like two pictures so this is
PCA you have a data set which looks like
this and you want to find sort of the
the high variance direction but in the
robust setting you might have some
outliers which kind of mess up your
estimate of course in this setting we
still want to recover this long
direction rather than the one which is
orthogonal to that which was sort of
planted a solution which fools us I just
want to note before I continue this is
sort of incomparable with the robust pca
setting which many of you might be
familiar with of Kandace at all I won't
get into the differences but we kind of
have just a gross corruption model where
say a constant fraction a few data set
is corrupted the entire data point so
this is the type of problem and we
wanted to investigate this on real-world
data set so we decided to revisit a
classical experiment a classical study
called genes mere geography in Europe
this was by novembre Dahl about a decade
ago and appeared in nature let me
describe their experimental setup they
did the following they took a high
dimensional genomic data set of several
thousand individuals in Europe they
annotated each individual's data point
with their country of origin for example
someone from Great Britain would have a
there their data point colored pink in
this case and stain would be blue etc
and then the researchers performed the
following statistical experiment they
took the top two principal components of
the dataset they projected onto these
two components and plotted the result on
the plane getting the picture here which
resembles the map of Europe pretty
closely so just repeat this in perhaps
less technical terms the researchers
found that the two directions which
correspond did us which explained most
of the variation in genetic information
seem to correspond roughly to the two
feet
in real world space latitude and
longitude and that's giving rise to the
term that jeans and mirror geography so
this was a pretty cool finding there's
one thing I didn't tell you about this
experiment though actually when doing
this experiment the researcher is
pre-pre they went over the data set
before and removed anyone who looked too
much like an outlier for example if you
have an immigrant from say Asia perhaps
their genetic code would be too
different and sort of mess up the
projection so they pre-screened their
data set and remove individuals who who
looked like they should be an outlier in
that sense so this sort of begs the
question can we do this sort of outlier
removal in an automated sense at the
time when we were doing these
experiments we couldn't get to access to
the full data set but we instead added
our own synthetic you know outlier
points in order to see how algorithm
would do so after adding our synthetic
data points as outliers we reran the
original experiment their original setup
just naively running a principal
component analysis and you can see the
results in this next slide right here
Europe is destroyed what about I mean to
say is that if you take the top two
principal components they no longer have
the information that was originally
contained here you lose the nice
structure of Europe so the question is
can you can you still recover this well
if you try other approaches say like
ransack it doesn't give maybe it's a
little bit better if you squint at it
not really clear this is an SDP based
robust PCA which is not quite suited for
this setting but you can see maybe it
looks a bit better but still not quite
clear but you can see our result in this
picture here which fairly reliably
resembles the original data on the left
you can see that there's some notable
changes for example there were only four
individuals in this data set who came
from Turkey and they've been removed but
if you only have four day of data points
in a set of thousands then plausibly
these could be considered outliers but
besides that I think the most important
thing to see that pretty much keeps the
exact the directions yes
if you apply your algorithm without the
synthetic outlets how differently good
question the question is uh imagine we
just ran it without adding more outliers
how would it look I think it looks to
roughly the same ad before I'm sorry the
same as here again we still prune
individuals who look perhaps like they
could be outliers but it gives
essentially the same result so I think
this is a promising experiment showing
that perhaps these type of methods could
be useful in exploratory data analysis
where you may have data sets that are
corrupted in this sense so this adds
sort the second vignette I'm going to
move away from unsupervised learning and
on to supervised learning but before I
continue are there any questions about
this cool and the final vignette I'll be
talking like I said about supervised
learning this is a different paper with
a similar cast of character but also
with Jacob Steinhardt as well and this
goes perhaps beyond just robust
statistics we're wondering if we can
optimize more complicated objectives in
this corruption setting so we're gonna
imagine we have the following setting
there's some unknown distribution D
which is over appearance X Y X is sort
of the data points and Y's are the
labels and we're going to have a loss
function which depends on the data point
and some parameter vector W and the
question is given an app slaughtered
corrupted epsilon corrupted set of
samples from some distribution we want
to find a parameter vector that
minimizes the expected loss if we took
another sample from the distribution
this might sound perhaps is natural to
some a few and weird to some of you but
I just want to give you it's a few
examples if you just plug in this
function this is exactly eat like linear
regression
similarly SVM's and more generally
generalized linear models so this is
just a general framework which expresses
all of these are there any questions
about the setup
cool and let me ask you if you wanted to
solve this problem
what would you do in a non robust
setting anyone have any guesses what
everyone's favorite algorithm gradient
descent so in a regular setting if there
were no corruptions you would just run
gradient descent so you can see here we
have a parameter vector WT and we update
it by essentially taking the gradient
the empirical gradient and multiplying
it by some learning rate and then
updating it essentially the intuition
here that we want to follow the negative
gradient of the function and I had the
proxy for this of course we don't have
this but the empirical gradient works in
the vanilla setting that is to say we
can just empirically estimate this value
based on based on what we see
empirically the question is though what
if instead of having in this these true
values what if some of the acts iyi
pairs are corrupted can we still
estimate this expectation well if you've
been paying attention you'll realize
that this is just a mean estimation
problem as was studied through the rest
of this talk so how do we robustly
estimate this expectation and we want to
just use a modified gradient descent now
so again we're going to update a
parameter vector by going in the
negative direction of some GT where GT
is now a robust estimate of the gradient
and this is just obtained via the robust
estimators that would mention in the
rest of this talk I'll comment that they
have distributional assumptions and it
bounded moments of the data in the data
space often suffice to bound moments of
these gradients and I want to comment
that the same the same idea with
recently also used by Prasad at all
for this problem so this gives rise to
our algorithm which we called sever and
the main result is something of the
following form if the covariance of the
gradients is bounded by Sigma squared
times the identity this is sort of our
main distributional assumption then our
algorithm will locate a approximate
critical point that is it'll
approximately optimize the function one
thing I want to sorry approximately in
the convex case it'll approximately
optimize the function but in general
even in a non convex setting it will
still be able to find a sort of a stable
point a critical point of the function
I'll note that you might notice here
that the covariance is bounded this
suggests that the right thing to do is
use a second moment filter which I
mentioned that's the beginning of this
talk and additionally we give some
specific sample complexity complexity
results for some of the problems like
linear regression FBI majestic
regression etcetera so there those are
sort of the theoretical results which we
have in this paper the question is can
we actually make it practical because
that's kind of the theme of this talk
the problem is that gradient descent is
pretty fast but using the filter is
comparatively slow so imagine you know
we run our gradient descent algorithm
each time we just take the empirical
gradient that's very very fast but
imagine we slowed this down by instead
of taking this the empirical mean we ran
this entire algorithm each time to
robustly estimate what this gradient is
you can imagine that slows it down quite
a bit
involving you know and I can value
eigenvector computation at each step
there's actually a much simpler way that
still has the same theoretical
guarantees in this case what we can
instead do is simply run vanilla
gradient descent run it to convergence
and then only once we reach convergence
do we filter out these outliers in other
words instead of running gradient
descent in other words instead of using
the filter on each individual step we do
a number of steps and then just run the
filter once and repeat until convergence
in practice this results in maybe like
only having to run the filter three or
four times whereas you know
otherwise we'd have to use it hundreds
of times perhaps yeah like I said this
give the same ish the reticle guarantees
but it's much faster in practice and
let's go even one step beyond that we
can also remove hyper parameters which
are involved in the algorithm in fact we
can just do the very simple algorithm
that I have here we can project onto the
top a single singular vector of the
gradient we remove the most extreme
points in that direction and then repeat
k times this is a very simple algorithm
to run there's no real it requires
minimal tuning in terms of the
parameters so the question is can we
actually run this and do we get
reasonable results we're just going to
create the I mean the covariance up at
Yahoo sorry yeah
so the question is can we actually
defend and how do we actually measure a
defense we have to get good attacks and
see if it we can defend against them so
data poisoning we're going to you the
data poisoning attacks of Steinhart at
all which essentially tries to optimally
attack a defense they have some
theoretical results some are heuristic
but I just want to say a few lines about
it suppose the attacker knew the
defenders strategy what should they do
this is in general a hard problem but
they give some partial results in the
sense that if the defender strategy is a
fixed strategy that is not data
dependent then their work gives a nearly
optimal attack using a no regret
learning algorithm of course non data
dependent defense doesn't seem very
strong but they also have some effective
heuristic methods that work even when
the defense is data dependent and they
have forthcoming work which bypasses
more defenses as well which is we we
used this version of the defense in our
paper so this is our experimental setup
which I'll describe we studied two
problems Ridge regression as well as
support vector machines we worked on
both synthetic and real datasets Diskin
datasets we use in particularly the
Enron spam corpus for a classification
which some of you might be familiar with
and we generated a very large suite of
attacks for a range of attack
percentages so ranging from just a very
very small fraction of the data being
corrupted the epsilon equals 0.5 all the
way up to 10% in some cases and we
compared with a number of other
baselines which attempt to remove large
points in some way or another so these
baselines remove based on things such as
say points with a large norm points
which caused a large loss things with a
large norm of the gradient or distance
of the gradient from the mean these are
sort of natural things you might do if
you were trying to heuristic lis remove
outliers
so this is the experimental setup and
you can see our experimental results
here for the problem of regression so
let me describe what we have here on the
x-axis this time it's a different thing
on the x-axis here we have the outlier
fraction epsilon that is how much of the
data we corrupted and the y-axis is how
much the test error is so lower the
batter of course and we compared our
method sever with a number of other
methods for example this line here the
teal version is a uncorrupted that is
points just taking the empirical answer
and here are other methods which in fact
try to prune in some sort of a naive way
and you can see that on synthetic data
we provide a much better answer and for
regression on the drug discovery dataset
which of the real world data set you can
see we still do a lot better and in some
cases if you look carefully when 0
percent error we actually do better than
what you would get uncorrupted and the
last plot here shows even if we chose
the attacks which make us look the worst
that perform best against our attack
against our defense you can see we still
do comparable to all the other defenses
and much better than some of the other
ones
that's for regression we also have
similar results for say SVM's where you
know in this plot you can see that we
perform comparable to the uncorrupted
answer and even when we target attacks
against our method we still do much
better than the alternatives and on the
real world data I'm not going to go over
all these one by one but you can see
roughly that the same story holds so
that's pretty much it just to conclude
this talk I want to say that robustness
is perhaps is this is a bit too too much
but I think this is a robustness is a
promising direction which deserves more
investigation in the real world using
perhaps these methods the things we have
could be useful in data analysis in
supervised and unsupervised settings and
I think the next step is really making
practical tools for more real-world
settings I'm very excited about
potentially looking into applications of
this sort that's all thank you
[Applause]
cool let me just say two things one in
case anyone's still around and wants to
socialize or hang out and meet people
after the stock deadline there's going
to be an outing leaving from the second
floor at 6:30 or you can email me if
you're if you want more info and second
I want to say thank you to the
organizers for running this awesome
workshop
[Applause]